bonjour bonjour je le connais de lui
merde le boss et leur [ __ ] ouais ok
donc on se connaît
tu vas bien très bien c'est qui déjà à
bordel mais je t'en prie ac toi on sait
qui on va bienvenus enfin c'est mort
mais c'est un pote à l'est des indices
là s'il vous plaît l'aurore alors ok
donc s'éteignent au lycée ni à la fac
n'est au travail comme ça tu cherche du
boulot
oui je crois qu'on peut dire ça comme ça
on imagine leçon moustache prend 29 ans
ça file ça n'est pas ça d'un coup tu
amènes et ravagé le pauvre je prends
très cher au niveau des golfs là en ce
moment là non ça va si tu sais que tu
assures passé temps puis commence à
grisonner un peu et un oui hein c'est
vrai un peu ça le stress quel stress
d'accord je vois ou alors non je dirais
que je suis quelqu'un de professionnel
donc plutôt plutôt très résistant à la
pression qui les gouges ce qui sort non
mais tu es stressé est à l écoute mais
je comprends vos dents c'est bizarre
cette situation la toile y six mois là
mais tu sais quoi on va le faire cool
hein on va le faire
ok voilà bon écoute je veux pas te faire
tout l'historique simplement là où nous
attend un petit peu au tournant
parce qu'il ya un vrai enjeu de marque
alors tu me parles enjeux de marque
je pense immédiatement à la loi des cinq
mrc marché alors moi je t'écoute
j'écoute ce que ok mais quand tu aimes
potes de potes 28 et [ __ ] il faudrait
vraiment je fasse des fiches sur tous
les gens que je croise pour m'en
souvenir ou un tableau excel un truc
comme ça
certains regardent passer la loi de cap
mercredi revient toujours à alex laurent
oui mais oui c'est ça laurent leur
envoyais alex et oui c'est ça c'est ça
ah je suis trop fort bon alors je vais
être honnête avec toi
la prochain album après tu postules ici
je te cache pas que c'est pas le
meilleur mais ouais ah ouais on est en
plein psychodrame d'entreprise tu aurais
lui la balle celle d'heuliez je sais pas
s'il va rester encore très longtemps
il a fait de la grosse grosse grosse
merde d'ailleurs c'est une merde on voit
là une merde humaine hashtag ben merde
humaine et à gaubert du monde
bon écoute moi je te dis tout ça c'est
que je pense que ça fait que les chaises
musicales bientôt ça change un peu la
donne mais ça change un peu la donne
ralala laurent et tuez pas compris une
photo pour alex voilà on est bien paré
tassant numéro deux qui part alex moi je
suis quand même plus jeune que lui bat
alex mais on se connaît le mien non il
est super beau super eux tu viens
toujours la maison
allez salut au revoir